but first in breaking news a court in
Bangladesh's sentenced seven people to
death for one of the worst attacks in
the country's history 22 people died in
the siege on the holy artisan cafe in
the capital dakar in 2016 nearly all the
victims of foreigners an eighth person
has been acquitted
Chandler Chaudhary joins us live now
from the Bangladeshi capital the
incident happened in 2016 and and
justice has been dispensed in 2019
a fairly swift judicial process well
first let me tell you about the Aquila
like seven people were given death
sentence and one was acquitted in this
particular case but he's serving 10
years for another particular case the
courtroom was packed we couldn't go in I
was by the door as you can see all the
media's and other curious and observes
are here it has been almost nearly a two
years now it took a long time for the
proceeding
little over 100 people gave deposition
and witnesses and since then at least
dozens of people were killed in
encounters with security forces some of
them were accused in two related to this
case members of militant groups who
supposedly were connected to the people
the gunmen who attacked the holy artisan
cafe now while this accused were taken
away from the by the jail then they were
yelling out that justice was not given
and the carry on the jihad things like
that some Arabic chant which I couldn't
understand but I could figure out they
were saying that justice wasn't done
carry out we are jihad now lots of
people have been accused of nearly
thousands of people are behind bars
under militancy and different kind of
affiliation with Islamic Jihad here now
the government has been denying that
most of these people are not affiliated
with ayahs or the - rather but they're
local militants some of them have
affiliation with al-qaeda but they're
completely on the lie of the fact that
these were influenced by the eyes from
outside while those
particular five people who were killed
in the cafe incident they uploaded their
picture which was on daya site site
intelligence claimed the dice claimed
that those five were directly affiliated
with eius during that attack it was one
of the worst attack or terror attack in
Bangladesh's history indeed and the
significance then of this attack did
that influence the pace at which the
wheels of justice turned in this
particular matter
absolutely I'm in the set up a special
tribunal call NT terrorists code they
also set up a special unit for
international anti-terrorism several
police elite unit were trained into a
special operation to tackle this
militancy it has been subdued to an
extent also there has been some
criticism against the law enforcement
agencies saying for some innocent
victims of other drug crime and other
issues we're also killed during
encounter plus usually the media don't
have access to these accused once
they're detailed or killed we don't know
exactly who these people are other than
what the police hand us out during this
investigation today is probably the
first time we heard but we still don't
know that detail what where the
accusation how were they involved where
they actually affiliated with any
particular international terrorist or
militant organization where those five
who were involved in the terror attack
who were killed during the storming by
commandos where they have any
affiliation with this eight accused we
don't still don't know fully because
okay so but the body has been given it
was rather quick in Bangladeshi standard
two years and you have the verdict not
right and their thanks for that time for
Chaudhary there reporting live on that
breaking news that sentences have been
handed down in that case involving a
siege on a cafe in 2016